hey guys I'm out of the country but we
didn't want to leave you hanging with no
good news so here's something positive
that happened what disturbs the out
of me is that after I got better
CNN MSNBC all these mainstream news
things are mocking me for taking horse
medication
there's a he took horse medication
he took horse dewormer like literally
taking a drug that's on the World Health
organization's list of essential
medicines literally taking a drug that's
been prescribed billions of times taking
a drug from that was invented by the guy
who won the Nobel Prize for inventing
that drug
best safety profiles of any known drug
but it's generic and it's cheap it was
real cheap
and I didn't just take that I listed a
bunch of other things I took a z-pack
monoclonal antibodies I had IV vitamin
infusions multiple days in a row I got
better quick nobody cared that I get
better quick all they cared was I didn't
get vaccinated what's the best way to
shame him let's point to this one thing
that he took and mock this person for
taking this foolish medication they even
changed the color of my face on CNN they
put my I put a video up of me saying
that I had to cancel shows Dave
Chappelle and I had a big concert coming
up that weekend and I said we have to
postpone it because I have covet
but I in the videos like I feel fine I
had covered three days ago I had one bad
day the second day I felt pretty good
today I feel great and all they wanted
to talk about like constantly every hour
was me taking horse dewormer it was in
Rolling Stone it was in all these things
horse deep Rolling Stone had an article
gunshot victims are waiting in line to
get to the hospital because so many
people are overdosing from horse
dewormer 100 percent
printed in the Rolling Stone not only
that but they used an image this is
Oklahoma they used an image this is
supposedly in the summer that this was
happening they used an image of a bunch
of people waiting in line wearing winter
coats
because that wasn't from that that was
from the I believe they're waiting in
line to get vaccinated for the flu it
was another stock photograph they used
to people waiting in line at the
hospital it had nothing to do with horse
dewormer this was tweeted by Rachel
Maddow this was tweeted by many online
prominent influencers and journalists
like look at these fools taking this
horse dewormer
and it wasn't until I read uh Robert
Kennedy's Book the real Anthony fauci
that I got a sense that this is a
Playbook that they have used forever
they offer one solution this one
solution is patented this one solution
is controlled by these pharmaceutical
companies and it's very expensive and
they make a load of money from it
whereas anything that's off label
anything that's generic is dismissed
they rig the tests to make it look like
it like they'll give you far more in
like what they did with
hydroxychloroquine to me I don't even
want to go into this you could read it
in the book but
my whole journey on this is like first
of all how did I find myself in this
right I'm a comedian and a cage fighting
commentator how am I having these how am
I on CNN all the time and all they're
doing is mocking a medication that I
took very deceptively no out and out
lying not just deceptively just out and
out lying saying that I took veterinary
medicine
it was so strange it was so strange to
be in the center of that
and also to be someone who got over it
very quickly where there was no
discussion there was no like Hey Joe
Rogan got over this really quickly what
is he doing differently than most people
that that had coveted and had terrible
outcomes there was none of that there
was no real concern like hey is he doing
something that we could all do maybe
some people like Aaron Rodgers who is
allergic to one of the key uh components
of the MRNA vaccine he literally is
allergic to it if he takes it it could
be bad for him so isn't there something
those people can do it wasn't even that
it was just mockery and shame and it was
also
a very distorted understanding of the
actual landscape they thought they were
CNN and CNN was huge CNN is the news CNN
is a gigantic corporations they have big
building the whole deal giant sign they
didn't understand that this podcast is
10 times larger than them and it was
exposed during that whole thing where
they just made this terrible chess move
they just ran out in the Middle with
their King
and that that's how I found myself in
the middle of all this